je vous laisse les choses je trouve sur
friedel d'une simulation hyperréaliste
de policiers on va devoir mettre des
doigts aux gens par des doigts sur la
prise qui relié à la chaise électrique
bah oui aux coûts poursuit ses parties
start alors pour de vrai c'est là c'est
sympa on doit en gros trouver le tueur
c'est un peu comme ce qu'on a fait la
dernière fois sur un jeu bien mais en
moins bien au revoir c'est parti alors
voyez ici on a les suspects ils sont
quatre et là on a un témoin qui nous dit
il à l'air riche donc est ce que ces
gens les riches m'a pas du tout deuxième
indice il a l'air propre et net à temps
mais à sa sacoche attend peut-être que
le plus loin au avec la petite couronne
et les bagues en or il est chauve
battant mongai un pas besoin sur la
quatre vingt dix bombes fumée noire
s'est clos qui s'abat content ça j'aime
pas trop est ce que c est lui allé
inspecter un squeeze trouve toujours le
coupable
c'était une balle à blanc cas suivants
allaient de troc est alors la
particularité de cette femme hors
michela des loupes à la place de le net
c'est que seulement 60 % des indices
qu'elle nous donnera seront vrai faut
faire très attention je suis sûr qu'il
me ressemble
elle aussi elle a des lunettes si je ne
vois pas je crois que lunettes elles
grossissent pas encore assez libre à
l'image que tu vois aulas peut child un
peu nul un bon deuxième indice on dirait
qu'il ya perdu ses cheveux lui il a
perdu ses cheveux l'apparence de tes
cheveux devient semblable à celle de tes
poils des soldats défilent sur une
calvitie beau troisième indice à je
pense qu'il a l'air vraiment étrange
attend qui n'a pas l'air étrange entre
lui et sa tête il lui est une question à
tête ça ils sont désormais tous vos
efforts il ne ressemblait pas à la peau
et les os quoi ils avaient la peau sur
les os je pense ça veut dire ce qu'ils
en pensent écoutez on va dire lien on va
dire lui aurait vers lui allez on lui
met un doigt c'est parti il était
innocent mais non mais changer de témoin
aussi c'est quoi cette grand-mère la
boum la grand mère où on fait tous des
erreurs
mettons simplement ça de côté wafa là je
vais quand même eu un doigt pour rien
quoi troisième jour by gold barney il
est raciste je pense qu'il ressemblait à
une personne blanche alors je crois
qu'on va marquer penser en rouge comme
ça ça veut dire que c'est faux c'est
dire que c'était pas un blanc donc déjà
on élimine le suspect numéro 3
adobe n'y a que des il n'avait pas un
corps de brindilles bon reste pas moins
un tour de bras ville d'oka mon avis
c'est plutôt un gars comme ça à la temps
on va voir les autres indices 3 et lundi
je suis sûr qu'il était chaud et à lui
qu'échoit est vraiment aucun poil sur le
crâne 90 je sais pas ce que ça veut dire
peau donc on va y aller au culot mois
gérer que c'est lui avec son crâne lisse
et lui c'est sûr c'est sûr je suis sûr
allez je lui met un doigt comme ça y'a
plus de respect quand tu es en train de
me lâcher carlos c'est ça on a résolu
tellement d' enquête toi et moi lui
plaît à jean camp du début annick l on
n'a droit qu'à deux fautes en fait avant
d'être licencié
alors il n'avait pas l'air anormal alors
qu'il n'est pas anormal surtout ce show
lula les suspects ils ressemblaient un
homme qui ressemble à un 1 1 c'est lui
lui ou lui un c est trop petit il
n'avait pas l'air d'un la nasa là bas
c'est quelqu'un qui a le regard fatigué
qu'à l'ère paresseux quoi alors oui il a
l'air paresseux regarder il a pas dormi
depuis huit jours lui je sais pas bah
moi je dirais que c'est lui un hôte est
ce que c'est lui est-ce que c'est lui
annoncer mon supérieur qui m'appelle je
suis dans la merde oui je suis licencié
c'est ça jour 4
[ __ ] on n'a plus droit la faune
négatif 26,6 all whites négative au nom
elle va dire que les trucs faux ils
n'étaient pas pas lui c'est lui qui est
pâle il n'était pas totalement obèses
ouais c'est pas lui alors il n'était pas
petit il ne ressemblait pas un gars qui
possédait une maison dans quelle somme
un sdf a baissé lui c'est lui mais
qu'avec ça pour garder c'est lui c'est
sûr c'est sûr voilà c'est affreux que je
vais me confesser après j'ai fait
installer un une église dans la dans le
salon a alors dit mme dunn il ya
toujours quelque chose qui va pas avec
lui impute un holà mais qui a l'air
fainéants lala donc lui dit que c'est
pas quelqu'un qui a l'air sombre quoique
ce soit ok il est plutôt favorable à ce
que le gars n'est pas de cheveux lui il
a pas de cheveux gilad échoué lui il a
des cheveux pas déjà on va on va se
battre jusqu'au temps pour soi carlos
suis ta gueule ce n'est qu'un simple
pistolet quoi tu peux m'aider ce con je
suis presque sûr qu'il avait l'air
d'avoir beaucoup d'argent va lui avec
son casque et son collier j'irai lui 1
c'est lui et l'annoncer pas trompé ah
oui mais c'est facile aussi un elle est
mon super va m'appeler pour proposer une
promotion
s'te plaît à pour les sorciers à du
monde en mai par contre après evil
édictées sifflets y a que la moitié de
ce qu'il dit qui est vrai au [ __ ] je
suis presque sûr que le criminel avait
l'air soigner d'accord donc jamais ni
lui ni lui ni lui ni lui ça va être un
de ceux là pour moi je suis sûr qu'il
n'était pas choqué et je pense qu'il
était petit oh là là on va récapituler
mettre les choses à plat
il avait la soigner ils pensent qu'ils
n'étaient pas jeunes il est sûr qu'il
n'était pas chaude et il pense qu'il
était petit on va trouver le gars qui
est soignée et chauffe ça peut être plus
un vrai mais yb avait ce que c'est une
maladie bavay et les choses qu'à moitié
après eux deux ils sont pas chaussé
elles ont l'air soigner lui lé suspect
laissé
hachez sa pancarte c'est lui c'est lui
mais je suis sûr c'est pas lui c'est
horrible ok alors dans black plus léger
en huitième jour sur 11g cartonné aux
gens en avant et le problème c'est que
lui il a pas beaucoup de temps donc on
va devoir faire très vite va enregistrer
son témoignage comme ça on pourra
réécouter au nom j'étais en train de
réfléchir à morges voulu me faire un
petit bilan et j'ai mis trop de temps
donc sage en train de mettre sur l'achat
d'un des copies non mais c'est
scandaleux
alors là on a une chance inouïe c'est
incroyable ce qui se passe neuvième jour
broken bella elle a des problèmes à la
tête il a le regard cassez vous lâche
pas trop compris on dirait un homme bébé
il al'air yuko du coup ça veut rien dire
il alla grossier j'en bouffe six mois
j'ai réduit celui qui a un regard
bizarre qu'elle est un homme bébé qui
est bouffie a laissé lui c'est sûr on
est allé tellement loin donc je sais pas
trop
russie 1 fr ouais bien jouer poteau
juste qu'il offrait les gens sympas de
cette vidéo sur finger à son ami des
doigts pendant plus de 30 minutes
c'était passionnant pour le coup de la
chaise électrique j'aime pas trop ce
délire mais bon c'était quand même un
bon jeu d'enquêteurs et finalement c'est
quand même fait licencier volaille au
rapid enquête bah ouais bah besoin de
vous plaindre à mon supérieur mais ça
m'a regardé n'était pas mêler de ça vous
a plu on se trouve très vite dans une
prochaine portez vous bien le château en
pis